[Music]
[Music]
Hey
I was waiting for some cats to jump on
it's early in the morning on Monday and
I got this theory man every time
something good happens for for DC Comics
movies Marvel comes along as quickly as
possible and kind of throws something
out there to kind of break the day so
remember like a couple weeks ago Justice
League trailer dropped and we roll it oh
my god
it's astounding like Snyder's done it
again and this looks amazing
lookit Aquaman riding on the Batmobile
so they had like two days three days or
something like that where they broke the
internet link to that Saturday and
Sunday because then on Monday Marvel
dropped the spider-man trailer and
everyone was like oh my god I don't know
about everyone but I was like nothing
will be better than this thank Christ
I've lived long enough to see the glory
that is the spider-man homecoming trip
and so then not to be outdone DC drop
acid [ __ ] news last week Warner
Brothers by way of saying hey remember
the guy that directed the Avengers now
he's been directed back or a movie we
got um he's a desi Joss Whedon making a
movie for DC Warner Brothers one of the
architects of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so that was a huge coup not to
be outdone man Marvel has just dropped
another pretty amazing trailer which
changes the discussion once again you
think you were [ __ ] psyched for
guardians of the galaxy and the
forthcoming Avengers movies nobody I
mean look I was I was excited for Thor
cuz of that hella but this [ __ ]
trailer they just dropped this morning
is one of the greatest things ever
happens the civilized world it is such
an amazing trailer right down to the
[ __ ] title treatment man it's so
[ __ ] metal this is one of the most
metal things you'll ever [ __ ] see and
top it all off they got the let out I
don't know how to [ __ ] they secure
the Led Zeppelin's on or how they
secured the immigrant song but they did
and it's [ __ ] hammer the gods
couldn't be more appropriate let's watch
the [ __ ] out of this I've already
watched it four times but come on man
this is [ __ ] glorious can you imagine
this is the world we live in now where
the [ __ ] third Thor movie looks
amazing like general when I was a kid
movies kind of you know sank and quality
the more they made this [ __ ] looks
fantastic this is better than anything I
ever made
let's [ __ ] watch this together here
we go man I got queued up and we were
impressed play right off the bat man
he's dropped and changed and then then
let him narrator I hope they do that the
whole movie [ __ ] chief Lance showed
up that was he's holding more near man
she's open and not only just holding
that [ __ ] BAM she shatters that [ __ ] we
got my money and then all of sudden
[ __ ] the legs are down
still exactly did you see the headpiece
the armies of Asgard pasted down-- king
Clancy take all my [ __ ] money
take my child's money get my family's
money this looks fantastic
there's a chicken please man sweet Helen
Albie
it's look madcap not better than any
formal daily seen before depressed
anxious yeah [ __ ] Goldblum for
Christ's sake man look at that dongle
treatment for this November
oh my god he's himself is there as well
Woking back main event time we know it's
coming here for with a very short man
put on the helmet boy hold that yeah
bets
[Applause]
come on his reaction towards Elgin
that's my reaction as well look at curvy
background
he's a friend can work [ __ ] take all
my money
look at that Tyra screaming you've
actually come unassisted my hands were
here and I just calmed that [ __ ] so
[ __ ] pain oh my god man we live in a
wonderful world kids I got nothing to do
with that movie I'm just [ __ ]
delighted it exists
oh my god more of that less of
everything else in this [ __ ] best of
all possible worlds thor ragnarok just
took a [ __ ] jump kids jump into one
of the most meaningful movies Oliver C
in my entire life
I like the trailer very much I'd said
thanks for hanging out let's go watch
the trailer a couple thousand times
Oh
[Music]